isn't that funny that the stories we
keep getting are all like this we all
have to talk about it and figure out the
nooks and crannies of it ourselves
without just getting the story like the
Alec Baldwin story too yeah like every
single time every week every day there's
a new story and we're like well here's
here's like uh 10 of the story but we're
not gonna this is this is important
right here because someone's super
chatted Cosmic Cosmic surgeon said I've
sold a lot of drugs but never in my
underwear dude wasn't even in his
underwear apparently that's what I'm
saying and he had a backpack
so I don't I don't I don't buy the story
man guy gets radicalized the cops get
the story completely wrong I I just
looked at him and I assumed that blue
jeans and a t-shirt was underwear whoops
the third guy actually same guy if there
was no third guy who opened the door for
you it was uh Paul Pelosi but he was
fighting with the guy with a hammer yes
so he's fighting with the guy with the
hammer makes his way they both wiggle
over the door he opens it for you as
he's fighting this is insane come on